[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport l'émission est toujours
consacrée à l'actualité sportive dans le
département à ces parties a pour le
sommaire foot us premier match de la
saison pour les templiers d'elancourt ce
week-end dans le championnat de deuxième
division et les élans courtois se sont
inclinés contre les léopards de rouen
les détails dans ce set 8 sport football
ont joué sur les terrains de 2e division
de district plaisir et rambouillet se
sont séparés sur un match nul
spectaculaire avec des rebondissements
le résumé à suivre pour sa pied le
parcours de l'eco trail de paris a été
dévoilée la semaine dernière depuis le
premier étage de la tour eiffel
plusieurs cours sont au départ des
yvelines dont 1 80 km plus
d'informations à suivre l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv5
[Musique]
mais avant de développer à ces titres
une bonne nouvelle pour le golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'open de
france aura bien organisés dans les
yvelines du 2 au 5 juillet un temps
pressenti pour être déplacé dans le sud
de la france sur le golf de terre
blanche dans le var
les organisateurs de l'european tour ont
finalement décidé de confirmer le sitv
noah jean louis charon le président de
la fédération française de golf s'est
félicité de cette décision chez nos
confrères de l'équipe
la dotation de l'événement ne devrait
pas dépasser les 2 millions d'euros
l'open de france est organisé à saint
quentin en yvelines sans interruption
depuis 2002 et devrait le rester au
minimum jusqu'en 2023 hameau de foot us
à présent le complexe sportif europe à
elancourt attendait ce match depuis à
plusieurs mois les templiers d'elancourt
était de retour sur les terrains ce week
end l'occasion de jauger l les ambitions
du club dans cette deuxième division et
le nouvel effectif des images de
marylène heye à pishin aux avantages de
romain arrospide les templiers
d'elancourt ont repris la compétition ce
samedi 18 janvier les élans courtois
accueillis au complexe sportif europe
les léopards de roi l'occasion pour les
joueurs y vinoy de montrer les muscles
et le potentiel de l'équipe dans cette
deuxième division
comme tout champion noble a débuté quoi
on est dans une boule d'or dans un beau
être dans une bonne dynamique
une bonne dynamique pour bien débuter la
saison comme ça pourtant de bien
commencer d'angoissé commencer par une
victoire ce serait bien pour la suite
des évènements en voiture mais le match
ne tourne pas en faveur des îles en
courtois les joueurs locaux sont dominés
et perdre la partie sur le score de 22 à
l'objectif de montée en fin de saison
n'est pas encore remise en question mais
les joueurs devront trouver rapidement
des automatismes pour remporter des
victoires
il ya un mélange d'anciens et de juniors
qui venait qui sont issus des sections
jeunes qui venaient polluer dans
après ma saison en senior donc ça change
un peu donc voilà enfin un temps
d'adaptation
voilà quoi après je pense que pendant
plus d'un mois qu'ils pourront bien là
pour apporter à l'équipe
les templiers joueront leur deuxième
match de la saison le samedi 1er février
contre les myrmidon de savigny-le-temple
toujours à domicile une équipe qui a
remporté son premier match de la saison
contre nantes on continue par du soccer
enfin du foot ball trap jouer ce
week-end contre eux aux devoirs à
l'extérieur à l'occasion de la 11e
journée du championnat de régionale 2 et
les trappistes se sont inclinés sur la
plus petite des marges 1 but à 0 un
résultat qui n'arrange pas les joueurs
dicha mazères dit rap est toujours 10e
sur 12 équipes engagées et flirte avec
la relégation ont joué à également sur
les terrains de première division de
district hardricourt s'impose 3 0 face à
voisins
même score pour mort pas face à l'ô
chesnais 2 partout qu'on entre à
aubergenville et sartrouville de partout
également entre le pecs et bois d'arcy
enfin carrière grésillons et où ils font
match nul 0 à 0
le championnat est toujours dominé par
gargenville et un mort pas toujours du
football un étage en dessous dans le
championnat de 2e division de district
match nul et spectaculaire entre
rambouillet et plaisir les deux équipes
évinois se sont séparés sur le score de
3 à but partout
le résumé du match ce dimanche 19
janvier les jaunes de plaisir recevez
les verts de rambouillet deux équipes à
la lutte pour le maintien en d2 de
district après quelques minutes
d'observation les rambolitains ouvre la
marque mais plaisir revient au score
grâce à ce tir en angle fermé 1 partout
un électrochoc pour les visiteurs qui
arrivent à marquer deux fois avant la
mi-temps 3-1 pour embrouiller à la pause
aujourd'hui très réaliste 400 cocasse
trois buts voilà c'est il faut s'adapter
tous les dimanches au match aujourd'hui
on s'est bien adapté on a réussi à
concrétiser ce qu'il fallait c'est
parfois un peu compliqué tactiquement
derrière on était patron place du coup
on a laissé un peu d'espoir ils ont pu
trouver la profondeur dans le dos et
clermont n'est pas rentré dans le match
comme il fallait alors les efforts ils
étaient pas que ce soit devant derrière
au milieu terrain au non match en
deuxième période plaisir revient avec de
meilleures intentions le bloc défensif
et plus haut et c'est grâce aux coups de
pied arrêtés que les joueurs plaisir aux
avons revenir au score 2 corner décisif
3 3 à 15 minutes de la fin du match
malgré quelques situations dangereuses
les deux équipes se séparent sur un
match nul spectaculaire
je pense qu'on aurait pu gagner très
franchement en tout cas c'est le
sentiment que j'avais sur le banc de
touche maintenant compte tenu de la
physionomie du match je le répète un le
score
le score nul et on fait quand même je
pense là la physionomie du match 2e mi
temps le discours c'est de pas flanché
justement ils vont rentrer avec d'autres
intentions un peu plus costaud gagner
les duels et c'est ce qui s'est passé on
peut espérer gagner le match
je pense pas qu'il puisse gagner le
match mais le match nul n'est pas
immérité c'est pas mal ce résultat
n'arrange aucune des deux équipes dans
la course au maintien rambouillet
toujours neuvièmes du classement et
plaisir 10e
la prochaine journée est programmée ce
dimanche 26 janvier un mot de basket
dans le championnat de nationale 3
trappe s'est facilement imposé sur le
terrain de rouen ce week-end le score 90
à 70 de son côté le chesnay versailles
s'est incliné sur son parquet contre
saint thomas basket le havre 76 à 72
enfin à marly le roi remporté sa
première victoire de la saison contre
fécampoise au classement trappe et 3e le
chesnay-versailles 4e et marly le roi à
dernier chez les féminines en nationale
2 le chesnay-versailles également connu
la défaite les filles de vinko berdych
sont inclinés sur le terrain de
dunkerque sur le score de 75 à 69
cette défaite est un coup d'arrêt les
chaînés ziana reste tout de même dans le
top 4 du championnat après 13 journées à
disputer du rugby maintenant direction
la fédérale 2 plaisir est passé tout
proche de l'exploit les plaisirs wac qui
luttent pour leur survie dans cette
division se sont inclinés dans les tout
derniers instants de la rencontre contre
le leader marcquois le score 16 à 14 une
occasion manquée pour le club les
joueurs de sébastien roncalli pointe
maintenant à une inquiétante avant
dernière place en écoute justement
l'entraîneur au micro de tv 78 très très
proche puisque l'on l'upci pompiers qui
sont quand même dans les cordes
buteur pour après ils ont donc eux aussi
est bon il ya plusieurs petits petits
détails qui nous coûtent encore une fois
la gagne malheureusement on en sait un
très bon résultat face aux premiers face
au leader de cette poule qui est qui est
vraiment bien armé donc bon on est on
est quand même on va essayer de rebondir
positivement encore une fois malgré tout
toujours en rugby dans le championnat de
division honneur l'union rugby centre
60,18 n'a pas réussi à s'imposer sur le
terrain de monter son château lui verser
60 18 s'est inclinée 27 à 13 mais
restent cinquièmes du classement survenu
dix équipes engagées
enfin en fédérale 3 ans jouer la 13e
journée versailles est revenu de son
voyage à sucy avec une victoire les
joueurs de la cité royale se sont
imposés assez facilement 42 à 23
une victoire qui leur permet de rester à
quatrième du championnat à seulement
quatre points du deuxième gretz tournan
verset jouera ce dimanche contre bobigny
pour un choc en haut du classement on
continue à part du rugby lundi dernier
le rugby-club de versailles a signé
officiellement une convention avec le
lycée à jules ferry pour la création
d'une section au rugby dans
l'établissement scolaire pour en savoir
un peu plus nous recevons sur ce plateau
nicolas apte à lui au reste le
responsable de la section professeur de
pfc entraîneur au rca versailles et
alexandre lemair entraîneur cadets où
air cv et intervenant sur la structure
bonsoir
alors depuis deux camps a été pensé ce
projet mais ça fait deux bonnes années
qu'on travaille dessus qu'on réfléchisse
dessus et on a enfin réussi à
concrétiser le projet lundi dernier avec
une signature officielle avec le rc reid
au lycée alexandre est ce que c'est un
projet inédit
oui c'est inédit parce que c'est vrai
que dans les élus n'y avait aucun lycée
qui étaient calmes et de section donc là
c'est le premier lycée et qui a une
section il ya plusieurs collèges mais
c'était inédit d'avoir un lycée pour la
continuité des collèges justement
pourquoi le lycée jules ferry jeu ça ça
permet aux jeunes versailles et 2
de continuer leur formation entre le
rugby et la scolarité et puis ça fait un
lien avec le collège apollinaire de
plaisir qui permet à ces jeunes élèves
de poursuivre scolarité et rugby alors
concrètement comment ça fonctionne alors
donc il ya 3 heures de rugby sur le
terrain une heure en salle soit pour le
renforcement musculaire soit sur la
formation sur l'arbitrage plus deux
heures encore avec en lien avec aussi
lui est né c'est ce qui permet donc de
totaliser 5 heures donc cinq heures au
total plus ouverts savent également
quelques heures supplémentaires ça fait
une dizaine d'heures par semaine si j'ai
bien compris de paul salem qui a dépeint
le joueur qui sont aussi inscrits au rcv
donc c'est complémentaire par rapport au
travail qui est fait à la section 10
heures au total par semaine est-ce que
ça a permis de progresser
ça permet de progresser on voit déjà
certains joueurs qui qui progresse bien
on les voir au club parce qu'on en a
donc sept qui ont signé aussi au rcv
donc on voit une réelle continuité une
vraie le progression alexandre est sûre
progresse plus vite
justement oui on pourrait ensuite parce
que on a plus de temps de pratique on a
plus de temps de technique individuelle
plus de temps sur la tactique et donc ça
fait que la la vision la technique la
vitesse d'exécution s'améliore à force
de répéter les entraînements d'avoir
d'avoir d'avoir comment dire toutes ces
heures permet vraiment d'améliorer le
niveau alors la section est ouvert
depuis septembre dernier il ya eu la
signature officielle lundi dernier mais
la section est ouverte depuis septembre
dernier
quels sont les premiers retours
justement aller retours sont très
positifs parce que ben et tante ou les
deux coachs au rcv on voit des progrès
des progrès dans nos joueurs et nos
équipes les sept joueurs qui sont à la
section sont titulaires dans
dans notre équipe cadets et après on
voit aussi pour certains élèves une
amélioration au niveau scolaire au
niveau de la concentration de la rigueur
du la progression au niveau de
l'autonomie gestion des devoirs et des
entraînements donc un retour pour
l'instant plutôt positif
c'est ouvert à tous aux filles et aux
garçons oui c'est ouvert à tokyo le
garçon pour l'instant il n'y a pas pas
beaucoup de films et c1 c'est un
objectif sur lequel il faut absolument
qu'on travaille donc je fais un appel à
toutes les a toutes les jeunes joueuses
du coin qui s'ils veulent connaître
cette aventure et puis s'investir dans
le rugby dans les études on est à la
porte est grande ouverte
comment fait justement pour pour ce
s'inscrire sur cette section
donc il ya un dossier à monter à nous
fournir avec l'aide de motivation les
bulletins scolaires de troisième ou de
seconde si jamais ils veulent rentrer en
première directement et après il ya une
journée de détection sur le terrain où
on juge aussi le niveau rugbystique
on est d'accord il faut avoir également
des bonnes notes à l'école il faut pas
seulement être bon rugby il faut avoir
également des bonnes notes à l'école
c'est clair que c'est d'abord et avant
tout un projet éducation nationale donc
il faut on mettra jamais les élèves en
péril au niveau scolaire
ça c'est quelque chose qui nous tient
vraiment à coeur
qu'est ce que ça va apporter au lycée et
au rugby-club de versailles à paris 8ème
versailles ça apporte de la visibilité
le fait d'être dans un lycée c'est quand
même comment dire assez importantes
comme c'est une première avec sa pente
de la visibilité visibilité par an pour
le club ça aussi une attraction de
joueurs qui seraient pas forcément venu
au rugby club de versailles mais qui
sont qui sont attirés par ce club
comme on le disait il ya sept joueurs
qui n'étaient pas de versailles de louis
club de marseille qui sont venus grâce à
la section et c'est aussi d'un pari sur
l'avenir parce que le rugby aujourd'hui
il ya deux ans un manque de licenciés
pendant que on sait qu'il ya des
licenciés qui se permet même si à
versailles on est d'un très gros et
comme hier on a un très grand nombre de
licences c'est vrai que ça
comment dire le fait d'avoir cette
section ça ça permet aussi de se dire
qu'on a un pied dans l'oubli scolaire et
donc du coup on peut vraiment avancer
sur cette voie là est ce qu'on pense
également à l'équipe seniors on l'a vu a
précédemment les bons il ya des bons
résultats sur cette équipe seniors qui
est qui évolue en fédérale 3 est ce
qu'un jour ces jeunes pourraient un jour
intégrer cette équipe c'est clairement
un aussi des objectifs sportifs c'est à
dire de permettre et donc en lien avec
le centre de perfectionnement que
jean-maurice obama et est en train de de
créer je suis adjoint au centre de
perfectionnement donc gg
j'ai un regard dessus et c'est vraiment
une un axe fort sur lequel on veut on
veut travailler c'est à dire lié la
section avec le centre de
perfectionnement pour former les
continuer de former au mieux nos jeunes
et d'intégrer l'équipe senior le plus
tôt et puis ouvre avec des éléments très
très efficace
est ce que le rugby est une bonne école
pour pour les lycéens ah bah oui
complètement cessé des valeurs de
respect c'est des valeurs justement de
sérieux qui sont tout à fait
complémentaires avec les études
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter ça
sera ma dernière question au avec cette
cession bail qu'elle perdure voilà c'est
ça qu'elle perdure et puis que les je
répète que les jeunes filles n'hésitent
pas à venir intégrer et faire partie de
l'aventuré
de plus en plus d'élèves également tout
à fait merci à tous les deux d'être
passé sur ce plateau on vous souhaite un
long partenariat entre le rc versailles
et le lycée à jules ferry
on va maintenant parler est des jeunes
sportifs qui vont marquer cette année
2020 pour connaître ses futures pépites
nous recevrons sur ce plateau gregory
canal est journaliste sur tv 78 ans soir
grégory basso mickaël alors il y en a
bien sûr des dizaines à suivre mais vous
en avez sélectionné 5
on commence votre top 5 par du basket
retenez bien son nom victor webb anyama
le basketteur originaire des yvelines
joue actuellement à nanterre il a 15 ans
et mesure tenez vous bien d'eux m 18
c'est un beau bébé comme on dit dans le
langage
filmant il l'a pas encore ça atteint sa
taille à définitive le sportif a débuté
au chesnay versailles victor un profil
qui lui permet d'être surclassé depuis
ses débuts il a participé à l'euro avec
les bleus et les a emmenés jusqu'en
finale ces statistiques 9 points 9
points 6 rebonds 5,3 contre le
basketteur également fait ses débuts en
pro contre les italiens de brescia en
eurocup en eurocup et il a joué 32
secondes
il ya également des pistards de l'équipe
de france dans votre liste on la connaît
depuis un petit moment mathilde de gros
la pistarde 20 ans qui s'entraîne au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
elle bat tous les records de précocité
elle est notamment double championne
d'europe du keirin et elle sera l'une
des têtes d'affiché de la délégation
française aux jo de tokyo est cette
année
autre pépite du cyclisme sur piste
sébastien vigier d'origine estonienne
il s'entraîne également vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines il
a 22 ans le sportif a déjà remporté
l'argent en vitesse par équipes aux
championnats du monde en 2019 et le
bronze à les deux années précédentes
sébastien viger qui a également remporté
le bronze en 2018 en vitesse
individuelle ils devraient faire les
jeux olympiques de tokyo cette année une
espoir a également dans le triathlon une
triathlète à suivre dans les yvelines
cassandre beaugrand la sportive de 22 en
lice ainsi à poissy a déjà été
championne de france courte distance
elle est également championne de france
d'europe et du monde en relais mixte
avec l'équipe de france de triathlon qui
a cendres a déjà participé aux jo de rio
en 2016 elle a été à 8e du classement
mondial en 2019 et sera probablement cet
été aux jo de tokyo
enfin on termine par un pilote
automobile
jimmy elias le guyancourt toit était à 7
ans et 10 mois le plus jeune champion de
l'histoire du sport automobile sur mini
kart il est aujourd'hui chez l'équipe
tony kart il vient de resigner à 11 ans
aujourd'hui il continue à enchaîner les
bonnes performances avec son équipe et
fait partie des pilotes les plus suivies
en europe
le pilote participera à cette année au
championnat à mini 60 géré par la fia la
fédération internationale automobile qui
regroupera les meilleurs pilotes
mondiaux il va notamment faire des
courses en italie on sait que c'est un
très beau berceau
ce duo circuit automobile mondial
l'italie merci à grégory pour toutes ces
précisions des futures pépites
participeront peut-être également à
l'eco trail de paris à cette année le
trail fêtera cette année sa 13e édition
l'épreuve qui sont organisées au mois de
mars relie chaque année les yvelines au
premier étage de la tour eiffel
au programme cinq distances dont 1 80 km
au départ de lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
la conférence de presse était
d'organiser ce jeudi 7 janvier nous
étions en sur place l'eco trail de paris
l'une des courses les plus importantes
en ile de france cette année quatorze
mille personnes se sont inscrites pour
l'épreuve
la conférence de presse avait lieu au
premier étage de la tour eiffel
[Musique]
cette année les qautre elle proposera
cinq formats l'existence 10 18 30 45 à
80 km au départ de lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines 80 km c'est
beaucoup c'est un parcours qui est quand
même assez exigeant on parle de du
domaine de l'île loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines avec un un
territoire elle est aidée des parcours
qui passe par buqueux versailles et
autres cette exigence est démonté ces
descentes c'est des changements de
rythme et c'est de la distance ont
beaucoup il faut l'entraînement il y
aura une touche de glamour sur cette eco
trail quatre miss france vont gravir les
marches de la tour eiffel pour
l'association les bonnes fées cette
année nous avons veille malama chavez
maeva cook et marie l'orphelin et une 4e
encore qui est en train de se motiver
franchement c'est bon enfant on le fait
vraiment pour notre association
grâce à l'argent qu'on va pouvoir
récolter cette année on va pouvoir
financer 150 et craint des faits sont
des sacs qu'on distribue dans les
maternités à des femmes dans le besoin
la course comprend également plusieurs
partenaires dont le département des
yvelines
les deux épreuves principales de cette
du 45 et du 80 km partaient des yvelines
respectivement du château de versailles
et de la base de saint quentin
en usine et puis aussi parce qu'il ya
les valeurs partagées avec l'eco trail
concernant le domaine du développement
durable la 13ème édition de l'eco trail
ce sera donc le 14 mars prochain départ
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines
l'eco trail sera donc l'un des rendez
vous phares de cette année 2020 dans les
yvelines des sportifs locaux vont
participer à ce rendez vous et ne le
manqueraient pour rien au monde fabien
parmentier de montigny le bretonneux
participera à sa 13e édition et
s'élancera sur le 80 km cet événement ne
fait pas peur à cette ultra trailer qui
a déjà testé ses limites sur de
nombreuses épreuves nous lui avons posée
à trois questions
[Musique]
j'ai commencé les courses
pour garder la forme j'avais j'avais
plus assez de temps pour pour m'investir
dans un club notamment un club de sport
de sports collectifs donc il a fallu que
je trouve un sport individuel et la
course à pied donc ça m'a permis
effectivement de deux mariés mon emploi
du temps de sportifs avec monopoly temps
professionnel donc la course était
vraiment par praticité
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir c'est le rêve de
d'ultra trailer que je me suis mis dans
la tête en 2011 et notamment ça a été du
luxe a été quelques années après donc en
2015 m finisher de mon premier ultra
trail du mont blanc
c'est quelque chose qui me fait rêver
donc j'ai réussi à passer ce cap là une
première fois en 2015 en 2017 et je vais
reproduire ça ans je l'espère en 2011
[Musique]
les futurs objectifs c'est déjà terminé
mon treizième eco trail et puis pourquoi
pas pleins d'autres par la suite dépit
donc à court terme en 2020 donc je sais
devrait participer au prochain mettra
trail du mont blanc d une nouvelle fois
c'est essayer d'améliorer un petit peu
mon chrono de 35 heures pour faire le
tour le tour du mont-blanc et après
beaucoup de courses encore qu'ils
peuvent me faire rêver tant que mon
corps me permettra de les faire on passe
maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
dans cet agenda du volley ball pour
commencer c'est officiel et ce sera une
première le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines va organiser une
rencontre de première division ligue à
le match est programmé le 28 mars
prochain dans la structure il opposera
les clubs de tours et de paris deux des
plus gros clubs de france objectif faire
salle comble avec 5500 spectateurs et
ainsi dépasser le record d'affluence
pour un match du championnat de france
détenu par toulouse avec 4223
spectateurs en 2011
on va maintenant parler d'un rendez vous
annuel dans les yvelines la 85e édition
du paris versailles menthe est
programmée ce week-end dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche au programme quatre
parcours de marche nocturne dont 1 54 km
pour nous parler de ce rendez-vous nous
devions recevoir les organisateurs ils
n'ont finalement pas pu venir à la
dernière minute mais nous pouvons
compter sur un courageux patrick sosa un
ebe noah qui va participer à 1 54 km mon
sort patrick ce soir alors patrick vous
n'êtes pas un novice un pourri puisque
vous avez déjà participé à plusieurs
paris versailles menthe
vous êtes un marcheurs aguerris on peut
le dire depuis quand vous participer à
ce rendez vous eh bien ce sera mon 29e
rendez vous j'en ai fait j'étais 28
paris mou de 54 km et un parent est un
saint nom la bretèche menthe de 38 km
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à vous
intéresser à l'origine
c'est le côté je dirais spéciale de
l'épreuve à savoir comparé à minuit et
déjà marcher la nuit c'est pas évident
mais si on est mieux on est mieux ou lis
que d'autres endroits
le départ est à 00h01 de versailles au
départ tout à fait et d'autre part c'est
se lancer un défi se dire une fois par
an on est capable de faire ses 54 km
parce qu'il faut gérer la nuit lever du
jour et puis bien sûr la distance et ça
m'a beaucoup plu
le premier était compliquée et bien sûr
au fur et à mesure qu'on a l'habitude
qu'ont à l'entraînement giresse ça
devient beaucoup plus en plus simple est
d'autant plus l'enfant lorsqu'on connaît
le parcours c'est vraiment un avantage
justement les parcours il y en a
plusieurs quatre parcours à 54 km au
départ de versailles à 39 km au départ
de ben à 22 à km depuis mollet 1 12 km
depuis jumeaux bill
pourquoi avez vous choisi le 54
kilomètres à bord ce que sa conscience
guy novès est prestige je dirais que les
autres parcours sont très bien pour
s'entraîner et d'ailleurs je
conseillerais à une personne qui hésite
un petit peu de faire le parcours de 38
km c'est ça compte la ferme et 30 mois 2
km et après si tout va bien de faire un
sweat 54 mais une personne qui marche
normalement à longueur d'année qui a
l'habitude fait partie d'un club de
marche peut à mon avis faire par hu man
et 54 kilomètres sans grosse difficulté
par contre je dirais qu il ne faut pas
non plus aller au delà de ces
capacités physiques parce que ça reste
une randonnée c'est pas une course est
faux il faut que sois plaisir quel est
votre meilleur souvenir
le meilleur sur les maïs et que c'est
l'année où j'ai il faisait un temps
vraiment très très compliqué ce bateau
isabelle leroy il y avait là la neige du
verglas et lorsqu'on m'a donné la
médaille
j'avais l'impression d'avoir eu vraiment
un cadeau ce candide alors qu'en fait
c'était pas mais j'avais fait et je
crois que je joue et je pense qu'être ce
qui est important dans ce pari
mentonnais et 54 même tout même dans les
autres parcours c'est de se faire un
plaisir en marchant et en se disant fais
pas ça tous les jours
alors ce week-end devrait faire froid à
peu près 5 degrés est son nouveau
maillot qui fasse froid aurait tout
avoué humide il faut mais qu'il fasse
froid parce que lorsqu'on a fait
confiance m'ont maillage du coup
alexandre est tout à fait lorsqu'on
marche on n'a pas froid du tout civil
gars couvrir et honnêtement même des
fois en marchant bien une vitesse unitel
disons un bon pas on est on absolument
pas froid du tout alors que lorsqu'il
plonge commun du grand frère 6,6 en
afrique à m envoyer à chenôve heures
quand j'étais plus jeune je faisais 8
heures et demie en moyenne ces 9 heures
9h 9h30
je pense que c'est la gronde
c'est dommage que les ordinateurs sont
pas là parce que je pense qu'ils
auraient pu nous confirmer que entre 9h
et 10h c'est là où le gros rôle la
bataille arrive bien sûr on peut faire
beaucoup moins 3500 participants je le
rappelle 3500 global global tout à fait
un doigt balle mais c'est vraiment très
mais j'encourage les gens à le faire
parce que c'est au moins une expérience
à faire à tenter
et c'est vraiment une très bonne épreuve
quels sont les moments clés quand les
ravitaillements or le départ déjà c'est
parce que le départ une ambiance qui est
déjà je dirais un peu les gens sont
excités ils veulent partir parce que
souvent le départ est à minuit s'il ya
beaucoup de monde et fois on attendrait
minutes un quart d'heure vingt minutes
les gens veulent partir et un peu de un
peu d'affolement et le ravitaillement il
est à mi-parcours aux élus et du roi et
puis bien sûr l'arrivée le plus beau
cadeau que c'est l'arrivée mais je crois
que quand on aime quand on a fait
plusieurs paris mantes l'arrivée quand
on arrive à 50 kilomètres on sait qu'on
a plus de 4 donc le plus gros est fait
merci d'être passé sur ce plateau
patrick je vous rappelle la date de ce
paris versailles menthe à la marche sera
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche au
départ notamment de versailles pour le
54 km si vous voulez vous inscrire et il
reste encore quelques places
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]